la comunidad educativa de Sao Paulo está
en shock luego de que un alumno de 13
años apuñaló en la espalda y la cabeza a
una maestra de 71 hiriendo también a
tres docentes y dos compañeros de clase
quienes están fuera de peligro según el
testimonio de un estudiante el agresor
había dicho anteriormente que cometería
el ataque y
le dijo a sus amigos que haría esto pero
nadie le creyó hoy cuando estábamos en
clase él llegó con una máscara de
calavera negra con un cuchillo y sin
tiempo para reaccionar la apuñaló en la
espalda y la cabeza
la Policía Militar detuvo al autor e
investiga los hechos ocurridos en la
escuela Estatal Tomás Y a montoro según
medios locales el perpetrador había
tenido peleas con otros Menores en los
últimos días y en su celular había
detalles sobre incidentes similares
sucedidos recientemente en Brasil el
gobernador de Sao Paulo lamentó el caso
suspendió las clases en el
establecimiento por una semana y
prometió medidas
la mejor manera de honrar la memoria de
la profesora Elizabeth es trabajar en
acciones para garantizar que algo así
Nunca vuelva a suceder nos enfocaremos
en soluciones para ampliar la atención
psicológica y medidas para prevenir la
violencia en el ámbito escolar en todo
el estado
el líder paulista informó que
implementarán un plan de protección
escolar para niños vulnerables junto a
apoyo psicológico y un refuerzo policial
si bien este tipo de incidentes no son
comunes en Brasil se han registrado un
par en los últimos meses y comienza a
hacer una preocupación